نبداها بحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وهذا
التطور اللافت حيث قال جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي بانه احبط هجوما ارهابيا
على المنشات النوويه الروسيه خططت له
الاجهزه الاوكرانيه الخاصه حسب تعبيره
واضاف ان مواطنين روس او مواطنين روسيين
تم توقيفهما على خلفيه مشاركتهما مع
اوكرانيين في التخطيط لتفجير خطوط نقل
الكهرباء لمحطات الطاقه النوويه الروسيه
مضيفا ان المواطنين الروسيين المواطنين
الروسيين جندتهما في سبتمبر من العام
الماضي وخضع لتدريب خاص في معسكرات
بمقاطعتي كييف ونيكوليف في اوكرانيا وتبع
بيان جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي ان من
وصفهم بالمخربين وصلوا الى مقاطعه بسكوب
قادمين من اوكرانيا عبر بولندا وبيلاروسيا
وكانوا يحضرون لمهاجمه خطوط الكهرباء في
روسيا البيان يشير الى ان مجموعات التخريب
الاوكرانيه حاولت تفجير نحو 30 خط كهرباء
لمحطات الطاقه النوويه في مقاطعتي
وكلينينغراد عشيه عيد النصر
اعلن ميخائيل رز حاكم مدينه سيفا ستوب
الموالي لروسيا عن تصدي انظمه الحرب
الالكترونيه والبحريه لهجوم شنته طائره
مسيره خلال الليله واضاف رز فو جايييف ان
الجيش الروسيه صده هجوما اخر بطائره مسيره
اخرى على سيفا ستوبل واسقط طائرتين من دون
طيار
معنا من دونيتس مراسله الجزيره كارمن
جوخادر ويمضي ابداء مع اذا موسكو تقول
انها احبطت هجوما على منشات نوويه ماذا في
التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
نعم سهام اسمحي لي بهذا الخبر العاجل الذي
هو في تطور في منطقه ومقاطعتي دانيت قبل
قليل او قبل ثوان تم الاعلان عن بدء خروج
قوات فاجنر من منطقه من مدينه باخمت هذه
المدينه التي كانت قد اعلنت السيطره عليها
قبل ايام وكان مالك شركه فاجني قد اكد ان
قواته ستخرج من هذه المدينه في الخامس
والعشرين من ايار مايو وهو ما يعني اليوم
هذا الخبر وصلنا قبل ثوان من هذا البث
ايضا في حول السؤال التي طرحته هناك
تفاصيل متعدده اليوم تم الاعلان عنها
الهجوم او الخليه الارهابيه وفق التوصيف
الروسي التي كانت تحضر لاعمال ارهابيه
بتفجير عدد من خطوط الطاقه وهذا الامر
مرتبط ايضا بتطورات اخرى يبدو ان وفق
القراءه الروسيه اتخذت منحه جديدا كيف حصل
هذا المنحه كانت قد ذاته القوات
الاوكرانيه منذ الحرب او اعلان الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا ولكن تكثف في الايام
الماضيه اولا يتم الاعلان عن هذه الخليه
وتوقيف اعضاء من هذه الخليه ايضا ما جرى
في شبه جزيره القرم حول اسقاط ست مسيرات
استهدفت هذه المنطقه التي كانت
عام 2014
ولم يوقع هذا هذا الهجوم اي اضرار وفق
السلطات المحليه المواليه لروسيا وايضا
هناك تفصيل اخر مرتبط بالحدود وما يجري
على الحدود والمناطق الحدوديه وايضا سهام
هناك تطور مرتبط بكل هذه
الهجمات التي قامت بها اوكرانيا ايضا
روسيا تقرا في هذه الهجمات وما اعلنته
ايضا وزاره الدفاع عن استهداف ايفان خرس
السفينه التي تعمل على في بحر في عند مضيق
البوسفور في البحر الاسود كل هذه الهجمات
ترى روسيا ان اوكرانيا فيما لم تستطع ان
تقوم باي تطور ميداني او باي نتيجه
ميدانيه جراء الهجمات التي تقوم بها بشكل
متكرر من جهتها ترى روسيا انها تقوم بقدم
مزيد من الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا ما يدفع
وفق القراءه الروسي الاوكران للقيام بمزيد
من الهجمات الاستخباراتيه لتمنح اوكرانيا
هذه الحرب منحا مختلفا جراء هذه المجموعات
الاستخبارات التي تقوم بالاعلان عن توقيف
العديد منها ايضا هناك توقيف لاحد
العاملين في احدى الشركات الدفاعيه الجويه
في منطقه ستوف كانت قوات الامن الفيدرالي
قد اعلنت عن هذا التفصيل يوم